but it's not something where in your
mind you go to
i wish i would have never served because
i didn't know what the life was going to
be do you ever personally go there you
know because diplomatically we can tell
people yeah it was you know any time no
problem but in your mind do you go to
man i i i
it's a rough life man that's not for
everybody maybe half the things i saw i
wish i would have never seen do you ever
go there
yeah all the time
um
i always say
people daydream
you know they always daydream about
holidays and happy things i day we dream
about other things and that's why i go
to my dark place and the demons
appear and stuff like that and that's
what i try and fight with till today
so still today yeah what are those
events declining or is it still the same
pace
same place and what are some of the
things you day dream of is it
individuals is it settings is it events
is it
visuals is it a loss of a person a
friend what do you daydream where do you
go it's a mixture of things it's a
mixture of
scenarios that i've been in
um close death scenarios that i've been
in
stuff that i've witnessed through my
sniper scope and
not be able to take this shot but just
observe
the devastation that people do
um and
just
people that i've lost friends
that i've lost through suicide and also
through serving you know on tours
everything that everything does it yeah
it's emotional it's emotional
how do you cope with it what's your
mechanism on coping with it is it uh
prayer is it music is it exercise is it
being around dogs animals music what
what is your route what is your method
uh two things one
is being around my wife
um she is my absolute rock my stone
you know and secondly i go to the gym a
lot
um
and
just lose myself for that hour or two
hours it's nice to lose yourself
you know and not think about things and
just
lose yourself in your music and your
workout and but also to come home
knowing you've got a wife to support you
as well i think that's a major thing
powerful do you listen to lose yourself
by eminem while you're working out or no
no it's called rob bailey in the hustle
standard got it okay so you go
completely different i thought you said
lose yourself you're sitting there
hyping yourself up to eminem so if you
like this sort of shortcut from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you